aller vite vite vite vite vite on
enchaîne le gauche droite très rapide
pas me plaindre garde la tête et
impulser une dynamique un rythme pour
repérer celles qui feront partie des 17
la sélection se veut de plus en plus
exigeante à l'image d'un sport qui
requiert explosivité et engagement ce
n'est peut-être pas un hasard alors si
l'on retrouve dans les rangs de ces
aujourd'hui rugbymen d'anciennes
albanaise ou athlètes du sprint celle
qui fut par exemple benjamine du 50 m
est devenu centre du rugby à 7
c'est plus physique en athlétisme on te
donne des directives et puis ça va de
plus en plus vite mon rugby faut plaquer
son homologue vais courir aux plaques et
donc c'est un peu plus compliqué la
claque à aux jo je manque un petit peu
cordiaux au but et puis après au fil du
temps se concrétise
si les univers sans varier les tranches
d'âge aussi ces jeunes femmes se
retrouvent tout dans un sport qui les
surprend parfois elle même mais dans
lequel elle retrouve des valeurs et
toute l'intensité d'un sport collectif
au tout début je voulais pas faire du
rugby du tout je faisais du foot et j'ai
c'est le rugby j'ai pas exactement
qu'est ce que j'aime c'est un sport de
contact mais
il ya beaucoup de cohésion aussi ce qui
motive à aller aux entraînements basse
et les copines qui nous attendent et
puis on passe de bons moments en fait et
on se défoule énormément également en
cinq ans le rugby féminin en martinique
est passé d'une découverte autour de
quelques poignées d'adhérentes à plus
d'une centaine de licenciés
sept clubs sur les huit existants en
masculins ont ouvert une section
féminine une source de fierté pour les
managers qui ont pu afficher ainsi le
meilleur taux de progression au niveau
national aujourd'hui ce qui fait la
qualité du rugby féminin c'est leur
détermination
il ya quelques temps de ça elle
n'existait pas aujourd'hui elles ont
envie d'exister dans ce paysage sportif
et encore plus dans l'activité rugby et
je les trouve vraiment déterminé très à
l'écouté et très demandeuse de progrès
et ça c'est une vraie richesse quand on
est entraîneur
défensivement joue plus de corps à la
connexion alliés pas
chacune fait son petit truc pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de lyon reste à
fédérer un groupe un collectif trouver
les automatismes d'une nouvelle équipe
d'ici quelques semaines il faudra
affronter les autres sélection de la
guadeloupe et de la guyane